المترجم: Nour Shaaban
المدقّق: Riyad Almubarak
السلام عليكم
الموضوع الذي سأتكلم فيه موجود
بين أيدي كل منكم
أريد أن أسأل، كم شخص غير قادر أن يقرأ
الورقة الموجودة بين يديه
الرجاء رفع أيديكم
نحن نتكلم أن تقريباً كل من في القاعة،
لا يستطيعون قراءة ما بين أيديهم
مع أنها طريقة معروفة للغاية وموجودة
بكل العالم
كما تعلمون إنها طريقة تسمّى
بطريقة بريل،
ولكنني الآن قمت بوضعكم بعوائق وحواجز
كبيرة جداً
وطلبت منكم أن تقرأوا بطريقة لا تستخدموها
ووضعتكم تحت ضغط أن تستخدموها
مع أنكم تستخدمون طريقة أخرى
وهي الطريقة المرأية
تخيلوا هذه اللحظة التي عشتم فيها هذا
الشعور السيىء أو التخبط
أو حاولتم التحسس على الورقة
لكي تعلموا ما المكتوب فيها
أنا وزملائي من ذوي الإعاقة السمعية
والبصرية والحركية والنفسية
نعيش هذه اللحظة كل يوم
وكل لحظة.
فقط لعدم توفّر المادة والوسيلة
التي نحتاجها دائماً.
كم شخص يبحث عن عمل أو سيبدأ
بالبحث عن عمل في المستقبل؟
الرجاء رفع أيديكم
حسناً،
تخيّل أن شركة تواصلت معك،
ولديك مقابلة عمل فيها
وأنت تريد بشدّة التوظّف فيها
خرجت من المنزل بلبس لائق مرتّب
فوجدت الجو ممطر جداً.
ركضت فالتقيت بشخصين قالوا لك:
طبعاً أنت لم تفهم ما الذي قالوه،
فاستئذنت منهم وتابعت طريقك،
مشيت في طريقك وأنت تحاول
إيجاد سيارة أجرة،
كل سيارات الأجرة لم تقف لك،
لاحظت بوجود رمز على سيارة الأجرة
فقط لمستخدمي الكراسي المتحركة.
فاضطريت أن تمشي ما يقارب ال600 متر
لتصل إلى الشركة.
في الشركة، بحثت عن الدرج/السلّم
ولم تجده،
فقمت بأخذ المصعد ولحسن
حظك كان معك شخص كفيف بالمصعد،
طلبت منه المساعدة ليضغط الرقم 2
بالنيابة عنك
لأن أزرار المصعد موجودة بطريقة بريل فقط.
دخلتَ على المقابلة وقاموا بتسليمك
ورقة، نموذج بطريقة بريل،
استغربت كثيراً وسألتهم: "كيف؟ ألا توجد
الطريقة المرئية التي أنا أستخدمها؟"
نظرت إليك وأجابت: "لا، تفضل على المقابلة."
عندما دخلت المقابلة، الأشخاص
الموجودين،
كان لدى كل منهم إما إعاقة بصرية أو سمعية
أو نفسية أو ذهنية.
ودعَوكَ للجلوس وقمت بالمقابلة معهم.
خرجت من باب الشركة، مرة أخرى باستخدام
المصعد، خرجت وأردت استخدام
المواصلات العامة، الباصات بما أن سيارات
الأجرة فقط لمستخدمي الكراسي المتحركة.
توقفت مرة أخرى وكان هناك شخصين
على كرسيّ متحرك، توقف الباص،
وقام بإنزال المنحدر، فنظر إليك الأشخاص
على الكرسيّ المتحرك وقاموا بإخبارك
أن هذا فقط لمستخدمي الكراسي المتحركة،
لربما تخبرونني أنني وضعت هذا الشخص بعوائق،
أو أن البيئة غير مهيئة لهذا الشخص
كي يتواجد فيها.
إذن لماذا لم نقلّ لمرّة أن البيئة هي
غير المناسبة للشخص ذو الإعاقة؟
أو حتى نقول أنه ليس هناك تسهيلات بيئية
يستطيع الشخص الوصول إليها؟
يقع اللوم دائماً على الشخص نفسه
أنه هو الغير القادر،
وأنه هو العاجز الذي لا يقدر
أن يكون في هذا المجتمع.
لماذا لسنا حياديين بالصور
النمطية الخاصة بنا؟
الآن تذكّرت عندما كنت صغيرة،
ومررت بحادث السيّارة،
كان الناس ينظرون إليّ بنظرة طفلة
بين أهلها تركض وتلعب،
كنت نشيطة وخدومة جداً،
كلّما احتاج أهلي لشيء كنت أذهب وأجلبه،
لحين وقت مروري بحادث السيارة
واستعمالي للكرسيّ المتحرك.
الناس بدأت بالنظر إليّ على أنني عبأ
على أهلي،
على المجتمع، وكانوا يدعون لأهلي بالعون،
وقد قاموا بإنهاء ما ممكن حياتي أن تكون.
صحيح، تعرضت للكثير من التحدّيات،
وقد كانت الحياة المدرسية
و الجامعية غير سهلة بالمرّة،
كانت العوائق هي عدم وجود التسهيلات البيئية
للأشخاص ذوي الإعاقة.
كنت في الجامعة أطلب من 5 شباب متفرغين
كي يحملونني ويأخذوني للطابق الثاني
حتى أستطيع الذهاب للمختبر.
وكنت عندما أريد الذهاب لكليّتي
لطالما ما كنت أبحث عن المنحدر
في كل مكان حتى أستطيع دخول الكليّة.
لحين ما استطعت مع مجموعة من أصدقائي
بإنشاء حملة اسمها (صار وقتها).
لأنه حان الوقت الذي يجب
فيه أن نأخذ حقوقنا مثل الأشخاص الآخرين،
والمقدرة على تلقي العلم كغيرنا من الأشخاص.
(تصفيق)
حققت هذه الحملة نجاحات كثيرة،
وأنا فرحة أنني أستطيع مشاركة
هذه النجاحات معكم.
أولها أنه أصبح هناك 21 دورة مياه مهيّأة
بعد أن لم يكن هناك أي دورة مهيّأة،
كنا نصوم من أول اليوم للثاني،
من غير أكل أو شرب
لأنه لم تكن هناك أي دورة مياه مهيّأة،
الآن أصبح لدينا 21 دورة مياه مهيّأة،
وأصبح لدينا منحدرات بكافة الجامعة
ومرافقها،
فأصبح بإمكاننا الوصول لكل مكان
بكل سهولة ويسر،
حتى المحل الذي كان من الصعب
أن أذهب وأحضر منه المياه لوحدي،
أصبح بإمكاني الذهاب وإحضارها،
أصبح هناك مصعد
الذي لطالما كانوا يحملونني إليه،
الآن أستطيع الذهاب للمختبر بكل سهولة ويسر،
وأصبح هناك مختبر بحاسوب ناطق ومجهّز للجميع
حتى يستطيع الأشخاص الكفيفين
الوصول للمادة التعليمية بكل سهولة ويسر،
وأخيراً ومؤخّراً، أصبح هناك مسار آمن
للطلبة المكفوفين، وهو مسار بسيط جداً
عبارة عن بلاطتين، البلاطة الأولى
هي بلاطة طولية وتعني أن الطريق للأمام،
أما البلاطة الثانية وهي البلاطة النقطية،
فتعني أن هناك منعطف يمين أو يسار،
فيستطيع الشخص الكفيف عن طريق
العصا البيضاء يعرف اتجاهه،
أكيد بدون مساعدة مرافق أو أي شخص
بكل استقلالية،
طبعاً هذه الشيء لم يكن سهلاً بالمرّة،
التحديات كانت كبيرة جداً،
وأكيد بدعم المجتمع والأهل
تمكنت من الوصول إلى هنا.
أحبّ أن أشكر أمي الموجودة بين الجمهور.
(تصفيق)
لأنه لولاها لما تمكنت من الوصول إلى هنا
والوقوف على هذه المنصة العالمية
والقدرة على التحدث وأن أشارك قصتي.
ما أريد إخباركم إياه هو أن التحديات
والقوالب دائماً تحدد الشخص،
ودائماً تنتقص من قدراتنا وشخصياتنا،
فقط لأننا قمنا برسم كيف
ستكون حياة ذلك الشخص.
وما اتجاهها فقمنا بوضع علامة على الشخص
أن هذا هو مسار حياته،
لا تتخيّلون كم أن الشخص
من ذوي الإعاقة عليه أن يقوم بجهد مضاعف
ليتمكن فقط من كسر هذه الصورة النمطية
التي بثواني قمت أنت بوضعها له.
لا تتخيلون كم أن هنالك أشخاص
ليس لديهم روح الإرادة،
بما أننا شريحة من المجتمع، فيوجد أشخاص
حسب شخصيتهم، ليس لديهم روح الإرادة،
أو ليس لديها هذه القوة لتتمكن من الذهاب
والمطالبة بحقوقها،
فما بالكم بما سيحدث لهؤلاء الأشخاص؟
هل ستنتهي حياتهم
فقط لأننا لم نوفر الوسيلة؟
فكروا بما يمكن أن تكون حلولكم.
تخيّلوا الآن إذا طلبت من 4 أشخاص
من الجمهور،
أن يصعدوا إلى هنا وأن يقوموا بربط الشريط،
وكان معهم شخص خامس عنده بتر بيده اليمنى،
وقمت بالطلب منهم أن يربطوا الشريط،
هل تعتقدون أن جميعهم سيقومون بربط
شريط حذائهم؟
ممكن أغلب الإجابات تجيب: أجل ممكن،
لكن الشخص الذي لديه بتر بيده لن يقدر،
تخيّلوا أن هذا الحكم قادر على أن ينهي
له حياته!
وممكن أيضاً ان يجعله بحاجة إلى مساعدة
دائماً، ودائماً بحاجة إلى المجتمع
ويكون عبأ عليهم.
ولكن هل تعتقدون أن جميع الأشخاص
سيتمكنون من ربط الشريط بنفس الشكل
ونفس الطريقة؟ بالطبع لا.
هناك أشخاص احتاجوا لباطن الكف واصبع
في اليد اليمين.
وهناك أشخاص احتاجت اصبعاً
فقط في كلا اليدين.
وهناك أشخاص ربما احتاجت آلة
أو ماكينة لتتمكن من ربط شريط الحذاء
بطريقة حرفيّة جداً.
لكن في النتيجة، أن جميعهم تمكنوا من ربط
الشريط ولكن الوسيلة كانت مختلفة
والطريقة نفسها كانت مختلفة.
بالضبط مثلما وسيلتي أنا المنحدر
وأنت وسيلتك الدرج.
ولكن إذا تواجدت الوسيلتين بنفس المكان
سنتمكن أنا وأنت من دخول نفس المبنى.
(تصفيق)
صديقتي آية لديها إعاقة حركية
بالأطراف العليا،
وتمتلك آية هذه الشوكة منذ 8 سنوات،
وبدونها لا تستطيع الأكل بمفردها باستقلالية
هل تتخيلون كم أن هذه الطريقة سهلة!
يعني هي عبارة فقط عن ربطة
تحتوي على ثغر توضع وتثبت بها الشوكة،
وبهذه الطريقة آية لا تصبح عبأ على المجتمع
أو أن تطلب من الناس المساعدة حتى تأكل بمفردها.
كم هو شيء بسيط للغاية لكن يصنع
فارقاً بحياة الأشخاص.
وكم نحن مقصرين باتجاه الشرائح والمجتمع
الذي أمامنا.
وهذا يذكرني بمثال آخر في أميركا
عندما كنت في رحلة تعليمية،
كنا ذاهبين لحديقة مهيّئة للأشخاص مستخدمي
الكراسي المتحركة،
والذي لفت نظري هو وجود مجموعة من الأشخاص
في الزاوية من كبار السن،
طبعاً دفعني الفضول لسؤال المرشد
عن سبب وجود هؤلاء الأشخاص هنا،
أتعلمون بماذا جاوبني؟
أجابني بأن هؤلاء المسنّين لديهم زهايمر
ويأتون لهذه الحديقة كل 4 أيّام،
أولاً حتى يساعدوهم بتنشيط ذاكرتهم،
ثانياً حتى يتم إنشاء مجتمع بينهم،
وثالثاً لأن الحديقة مهيّئة لجميع الأشخاص
وتستقبل جميع الشرائح.
هل فكّر أحد منكم هنا بكبار السن؟
أو حتى فكّر كم أن وسيلة
المنحدر يمكن أن تفيدهم؟
أو حتى عندما تصبحين أنت أماً ولديك
عربة للطفل كم أن المنحدر سيفيدك،
أو حتى كم بإمكانه إفادة صديقتك التي كسرت
ساقها ولو بشكل مؤقت،
الذي نستنتجه هو أنه إن وجدت هذه الوسائل
في كل مكان أو إذا استطعنا أن نوجدها،
سنستطيع أنا والأشخاص من غير ذوي الإعاقة
سنتمكن من الوصول لأي مكان.
وما أطلبه منكم الآن هو أن تعودوا
إلى منازلكم وتلقوا نظرة على البقالة
التي بالقرب من منزلكم،
هل يستطيع شخص من مستخدمي الكراسي المتحركة
دخولها بكل سهولة ويسر، تناول الأغراض،
يدفع ثمنها، ويخرج بكل استقلالية؟
إذا كان الجواب بالنفي، إذن فكّروا
بما يمكن أن تكون الحلول لديكم.
وأخيراً نستنتج من كل الحديث الذي تحدثته
أن مشكلتنا تكمن في عدم تقبل الاختلاف،
الاختلاف بكافة وسائله وأشكاله،
الاختلاف بالطريقة المقدّمة،
الاختلاف بطريقة التفكير،
أو حتى الاختلاف بربط الحذاء خاصتنا!
أو الاختلاف بالشكل أو اللون.
دورنا أو مسؤوليتنا أن نتجرد من أي صورة
نمطية وأن نكون حياديين بالصور خاصتنا،
وأن نتجرد من أي أحكام نضعها على الناس
بناءً على شكلهم،
أو أن نضع عليهم علامة
بأنهم غير قادرين أو عاجزين.
مهمتنا ودورنا هي مساندة بعضنا
في رحلة الحياة هذه.
وأخيراً، أحبّ أن أختم بجملة أنه
لولا اختلافاتنا لما كان للحياة نكهة
نحبّها ونستكشفها ونعيشها.
(تصفيق)